[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about what happened there was
like no energy
well because i wanted to say welcome
back to off the [ __ ]
yeah you gotta go i can't hear you
this side come on guys anyway we got
cat here you might know her from fighter
and the kid and
uh stranger's only fan request would
have to be uh photos on my armpit
did you do it shaved or unshaking people
are awesome they just wanted to see like
what it was so they're like
naturally i had a little hair at that
moment and then on another day
uh i was completely shaving they want it
real yeah they wanted real they wanted
another
this is when they asked for things that
aren't even their privates yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome
not shoulder bicep photos i've been
asked for a belly button photo
wow when someone asked for a bicep
picture do you pump up first a little
bit
no they were like i want you like
natural and then like i just like rolled
up my sugar
imagine they're like okay
she does one of those i'd be tired
[Laughter]
so then when they ask you for these you
set a price for that photo beforehand 20
dollars
um most of the time i will ask them uh
well what are you comfortable paying
uh paying you're such a nice negotiator
just to see kind of like get a feel for
it because i'm kind
i'm still very new to all of this so i
don't know what is necessarily
expensive and what isn't i found that
expensive
is subjective to who is willing to buy
it
so it's one of those things where most
people will say that like my only fans
is priced very fairly where
it's only ten dollars a month and in the
like every day you get two photos so you
get like 60. that seems like a lot of
content yeah
whereas a lot of only fans uh girls will
post here and there like a lot of girls
who do it will do
like maybe two times a week or so you're
like the forever 21
of only fans i'm like very scheduled
like you will always get content out of
me you
always uh get a response from dm i use i
do it as a job shut it up what is it
what is it my only fan
is onlyfans.com teen t
i i i e e e n three eyes three e's
yeah uh i got some weird requests
it's not always just nudes though like a
lot of people want to see nudes but i
don't do nudity
and i don't do porn my boyfriend is
[ __ ] though like a lot of people i
see
like go into it thinking like i'm gonna
do porn he does porn he used to yeah he
used to do porn with his ex-girlfriend
so like when did you ever watch any of
that stuff uh no but the moment i
told people who i was dating because
he's friends with my bosses on the
podcast and i met him
through work can you mention his name on
our channel oh yeah it's uh his name is
stevie blue eyes uh
would you know him he doesn't go by like
his government joshua guys that much
old-school like boston dude so he like
has like shady names
was he was he like popular in the early
2000s
uh he's like early 2000s i don't know
he sounds handsome who was his chick his
name is um
uh anderson nicole aniston he looks like
he would i don't know them
that's my boyfriend he's handsome he's a
handsome guy
if your name is stevie blue eyes you're
a handsome dude looks like a [ __ ] gi
joe yeah
he's like a compact gi joe he's like a
shorter guy yeah all right
this one yeah it's that one if anyone
calls you something whatever eyes
like nikki brown eyes yeah you know that
sounds like oh that's a pretty boy's
name
yeah that's a heartthrob right there
yeah yeah
yeah but yeah he used to do porn and
then he is also a
comedian i met him when he was i think
like on the
like end stage of him doing for like him
and uh his ex-girlfriend worked together
anymore but they were still kind of
shooting here and there
and when uh he and i met i was like oh i
want nothing to do with him
he just everyone talked about him like
he was this like
urban legend in the like fighter in the
kid podcast community
where he's like oh this is like a
fuckboy felon out here like [ __ ] porn
stars left and right
and he's like hi my name is stevie i
think you're really pretty he's super
wholesome
but he's like he's like been to federal
prison for nine years like his 20s were
like taken from him
and he's just like i like doing interior
design
designer bro he loves what is he the
dream guy or what he
really is like super wholesome he's like
hg tv
what does his place look like uh like
martha stewart you won't let me
touch anything in our home like he
decorates everything he's like do not
touch a thing like how have you been
together
uh since august not that long actually
and like i r
we like russia i wonder if it's like
being so deprived in prison with just
these concrete walls
now he's like in this world of colors
and [ __ ] fabrics and he's just like
yeah
and if in prison everybody knew him as
the interior design guy like
oh dude he's got the steve blue eyes got
the cool to sell bro
when you know that your guy was in porn
and you're about to have sex for the
first time what's that like
i was so intimidated because like the
first time i went over to his apartment
and we hung out like i didn't i was like
nervous to like get close to him to
touch him because i was like
if we start making out we start dry
humping and i start like feeling what
he's working with i don't know
like how important because on the
podcast they were talking about how big
his dick is
like as an inside joke and he actually
showed uh the producer chin and i
a picture of his dick and i was like oh
okay and he had like this tattoo of
homer simpson like on his inner thigh
he had cancer as a kid and you want
everyone to like laugh
he was like before i die i want to like
everyone cancer as a kid he had such an
unfortunate life that nobody was great
but he's like the happiest person ever
he wanted it so like when he passed away
everyone would like they would unclothe
them and see like homer simpson with his
like face like
right next to a huge that's great
like the dope face like right next to
like a huge dick
so there's that uh but when like we
[ __ ] for the first time i was like
huh brace yourself i was like holding on
to everything like yeah did you have a
wheelchair by the bed
i thought i would need to i thought i
would she had to leave in crutches
i'm a fairly sturdy lady but i was
definitely walking a little funny the
next day
i talked on a show about him and i being
together people would like send me
screenshots of him doing porn as if like
i didn't already know that's nice
they sent you screech they're like by
the way your boyfriend i'm like yeah
just so you know like is this your
boyfriend i'm like yeah
by the way [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't
know people out there
so does that mean you get a ton of
requests then from people yeah a lot of
people
there are people who will buy my only
fans trying to see like different nudes
from him
wow they're like i want to see his dick
like you're great but like
guys yeah like i can't get a hold of him
so he can tell
me pictures of his dick in different
like positions but like i can buy yours
to ask you if you like
obviously you your parents know about
your only fans and stuff but you're now
bringing a porn star home what's that
like
uh my parents met him and all they
really know is i think i told my
mom and my dad at some point but then
they forgot in their head they're like
oh he's dated like a playboy model i'm
like sure yeah
we'll leave it at that like my parents
are kind of like my family
is a bunch of degenerates anyways so
like it's fine
do you want to pay the big two as long
as it's like a nice
guy who's like taking care of me and
like protecting making sure like i'm
safe
really into your design and like now
that they know i'm making money they're
like oh she doesn't need a man how did
you go to usc if like everyone's a
degenerate how was college even on the
radar um
i wanted to go to school far away from
san jose because i had like crazy tired
parents i just wanted to get out i was
like if i don't leave for college
i'm never [ __ ] leaving the city so i
need to like try my best to
get to where as far as i can without
being like ella's not that far
it's not that far but it's far enough
for like my parents not to like always
come and check up it was like
too much driving like i was gonna go to
usc or like nyu and
new york was so far in my head and so
scary because i would watch law and
order svu
as a child i was like i'm gonna get
[ __ ] right that'll do it
so so you go to usc instead where the
whole
school is surrounded by crazy ass [ __ ]
yeah that's the thing i actually had
some homeless friends like when i was
going to
usc because i would walk from my
apartment to campus and there was always
like a few
people dressing like all black but they
didn't look homeless is the thing
and like there'd be this guy on the
court who would always nod to me
everywhere like hey what's up good
morning
and one day like i saw him like crawl
into a tent i was like
oh you're homeless but you're like the
closest thing to a friend i have in the
city so what's good
are you tired of using lime to clean up
your face
for a beauty routine well if you're
anyone like me
and you don't want to use lime anymore
like you don't want to feel like a taco
like this
if it goes in your eyes oh yeah that
might happen oh no
but like joe was saying if you're tired
of making
up your own skin routines it burns
what's up about curology is after you
sign up and you share your goals a
license provider gives you a custom
formula
to reach the goals that you want so you
don't have to put lime all over you you
don't have to use a bag
of limes for your skin care treatment
that man so thank you very much curology
because they helped me out in this
process it was super easy i went on i
said these are my goals
i want beautiful skin i want to smell
like limes i don't want to look like a
36 year old smoker
okay i'm gonna look like a 12 year old
uh surfer boy
right with great tan skin so they said
i'll hook you up this is what you need
this is your perfect
formula for you they sent it over and i
no longer have to use limes anymore
and what's awesome is once you sign up
they ship it right to your door so it's
super convenient
for 30 days and if you sign up right now
you can get it for free
that's right for a whole month yep so if
you're ready for healthier skin
and you're not trying to put limes or
oranges or other crazy ass fruits on
your face go to curology.com off the
record to get a free
30-day trial it's a whole month all you
have to do is pay for shipping and
handling
go to curology.com off the record for a
free 30-day trial
thank you curology get your skin right
and you don't have to burn your eyeballs
with the limes
it burns i gotta wash it there's
there's so many clean homeless but the
backpack is usually a giveaway for me
i'm like okay when they're going to
school what's that when there's
a character maybe he's like an adult
student
that's the craziest thing i've seen uh
so i was just in sacramento
and they have that is it called the
american river you're from the like yeah
right american river right yeah on the
riverbed i see like tents and stuff
which is what i'm used to seeing
there's cars there too now and the car
is covered
in like a tarp but there's just
straight-up parking spaces
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i never knew
homeless people had cars like you just
assume
people are down and out on their luck
but then now you're like oh sometimes if
some of this is by choice some of this
is like through
maybe just anti-society or whatever and
i'm like this is [ __ ] crazy
living space especially in norcal it's
so expensive well sacramento
are living in their car to like let me
live in my car in an area with other
people
i've seen i've seen since covid hit i've
seen trailers
in like the sepulveda area like all of a
sudden just start stopping
trailers that's crazy and then they look
like old trailers from the 70s that
don't even run anymore but
somehow it shows up and it's parked on
the street
yeah like main street off the five
there's just like six rvs
there's a lot dude rvs are mobile homes
because those are two
no these are rv weird corruption too
because um san francisco just got called
out for
cr basically they had these special
spaces for homeless people right and
then they spent like 16 million
on like tents to house them
16 million wow they know they have those
tiny homes that they're building
they're at least made out of wood no
these are actual
like you'll see it it's like they
spray-painted blocks right so they're
firefest antifa tents yeah and then they
just have
like coleman camping tents not even rei
you know wow and and then the the city
they spent 16 mil on that what yeah
i know someone's definitely embezzling
oh [ __ ] oh i bet someone
coleman's pretty happy too it's like a
family member that
owns something how long have you been in
la for uh i've been in la since
2015 so like a hot minute oh [ __ ]
yeah and you came all to escape and then
you just said stayed here
yup i i left like a refugee like i
brought one
like the clothes on my back i was like
[ __ ] it i was like i gotta go
were your parents pissed because um like
a lot of my like vietnamese friends like
they um
you know if they're girls especially
like they're like why you gotta go to
university so far why don't you just
[ __ ] go to this one right here and be
a pharmacist or whatever did you have to
deal with that
yeah definitely my i was i'm the oldest
in my family and i'm the first to like
actually go to college like my mom went
to like
fit him for a semester when she came to
america uh
but she in her head she's like okay well
if you're getting an education from a
school like usc like i'm sure you're
gonna learn something
like theater isn't the thing we want you
to go into but at the end the day like
you're gonna get
a degree from usc so it'll probably like
parlay you into something else which is
good
so they were fine with that and my dad
is so cute he would walk around
telling people like oh my daughter gone
to usc and then they'd be like oh cool
what is she saying he's like
anyway he's like i was like trying to be
an actress
everybody so they didn't they they
weren't
pissed at the fact that you had to like
go so far
no they were why don't you go to
stanford or somewhere closer i'm like
girl i couldn't get into stanford
what are you talking about i can't spell
wednesday without saying
wednesday that's all of us yeah bad
nobody can guys i got into usc i've
never added a d
until in my 20s restaurant is another
hard one
restaurant rest all along i can't spell
it straight up a gun on my head
making me small restaurant or guarantee
uh yeah guarantee is rough
too many using an entrepreneur that
couldn't spell entrepreneurs
that's a tough one too but because my
parents are vietnamese like they were
disappointed
until like i started making money the
moment i started making money they're
like okay she's fine
huh you get to show them pay stubs uh
not pay stuff but like my mom is so
old school vietnamese that she's like oh
yeah like she wants to see like
my bank account she wants to see like
what i'm doing with my money what are
you spending on
what i'm spending on you spend this much
on postmates like mom it's fine
it's fine uh but yeah she as long as i
am taken care of and i am not asking
them for money in her head she's like
it's a success
it's as good as we could have like asked
for with you in a theater degree
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] cool what about
your other siblings
um my younger sister went to school for
public health over in ohio state she
didn't want to move back to
san jose so i let her uh live with me
she's living with my boyfriend and i
here in l.a and then uh my younger
brother is like 10
11. so he's like a little baby yeah and
everyone's trying to get out of the
house
the only person who believed in me was
my grandma my grandma
used to yeah like my super super like
kind gentle super pc grandma not like my
like
rowdy vietnamese like cutting like a
sailor grandma she's like
no she may not get paid a lot but she's
gonna be fine now she's like i told you
[ __ ]
leave my granddaughter alone she's
selling pictures of her feet online
she's like she's gonna find a way
awesome so she's super supportive she's
super supportive she's like i don't
really know what it is you do
but okay it's fine you're fine i'm
rooting for you
that's tight she's so chill about it
yeah she's like as long as you're a good
person it's fun she's super like
buddhist super like you know what like
she speaks to me in like
confucius like i don't get what you're
saying half the time but i know you mean
well
you're praying for me that's tight
yeah is that kind of similar to your mom
yeah but she's not as kind-hearted
like super kind-hearted and mellow or
you're like super strict like aggressive
the other way
it's so bipolar yeah my mom my mom like
so true
she so she has this buddhist mindset and
like asian tiger like logic right
so she only understands it in her own
way
yeah so i've been giving my mom
allowance like since we could afford it
so maybe like i don't know since maybe
2013
2014 like i just i pay her um just so
she can like
retire and live very comfortably when i
got into bitcoin and cryptocurrency like
last year or this year
you know that and uh i started 2017.
well 2017 yet but i really started
thinking about like staking and stuff
in uh i think just either this year or
last year i forgot
but whatever money i was telling my mom
that i was sending her i was like hey
instead of me i'm like do you really
need this money
yeah because if you don't what i want to
do is i'd rather pay that and put it
into like one of these staking accounts
and i could build it that way at the end
of the year you could still
um get the money that i was going to
give you anyways
but at least you'll have the interest
and it grows and then you know
cryptocurrency is going up
and i think she just zeroed in on the
part where like wait
why are you calling me homeless for you
think i need your money i don't need
your [ __ ] money and i'm like oh she's
like proud
that's not that's not the point the
point is i'm like if you have retirement
she worked like 30 40 years at another
job so i know she has retirement she's
wealthy dude yes i'm like
i'm like you have money i'm like if you
don't need this money
i can put it somewhere else and they'll
grow even more uh but if you're gonna be
homeless i don't want you to be homeless
yeah and then she got so stuck on the
homeless like how dare you [ __ ] call
me home is i don't need
i don't need [ __ ] from you all i need is
the temple
i don't even [ __ ] talk to you
probably your wording i don't even
[ __ ] talk to you anymore
and then the father was saying hey mom
you know how you're a broke-ass [ __ ]
you need my money she's like i don't i
don't wanna [ __ ] take her money and
she stopped talking me for like three
months
oh wow and the normal people's time
that's probably like five years because
my mom will text me like two or three
times a day
yeah so a million dollars that we don't
talk about you just gotta piss her off
every now and then if you don't want to
talk to her yeah but the thing is
i started feeling sad oh my mom hasn't
talked to me in a while and i felt bad
and then the minute she texted me
the first thing she texted me was a
video of like some [ __ ] buddha like
story and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i wish i pissed
dude my family's similar where like i
remember during
crypto when it was going down and [ __ ]
yeah my family's all like
nah dude not doing that [ __ ] it's all a
big [ __ ] scam bubble pop all this
[ __ ]
but my little brother he rode with me
the whole time now he's retiring
and my family doesn't want to talk about
it
that's my best man that's the best story
you want to hear
the best and he just he just like moved
with me when i moved all [ __ ]
and i was telling i would text them now
and then like hey just so you know this
is about to you know run
it's gonna be good this will be a good
one and then i'll just like yeah it's
like putting money into a furnace
they they would respond like that
instead of like just listening or maybe
being like i don't know like yeah i need
more information
like nah that's like boom wrong that's
bad to do
yeah how many failed investments did you
pitch to your family
in the past that's how i was looking at
it with my mom i was like mom you're
getting scammed again with bitcoin i
don't know
oh yeah you got to know why you bought
it that's all yeah
no but that's probably that's where
you're trying to ask khan like if they
had
already like yeah where does this come
from like
because some people are just hella
negative that's bad and they're
skeptical even
no matter who says what that's what and
then some people just like
yeah maybe steve sold his family into a
ponzi scheme that we don't know
i got them into rvs early
before the downturn it was hot for a
minute too though
oh yeah rv's are hot now yeah they're
great everyone's ever looking at their
hands
yeah you know how many youtubers we
watch of people living in vans i don't
know why we watch it but we love
suvs were dying out until rona
yeah yeah you can't fly anymore miatas
you know
no no no no never i don't think you
nadas are going to come back
i don't know dude hey your boy just hit
me up about a miata recently so
who's your boy chris oh cause he has one
already that's the only reason why
i sold my miata for a pretty good chunk
of change oh you sold it
i sold it dude i had i had it for it's
like a very it's a must it's a car that
everybody makes fun of
no no it's it's a fun car to drive like
they're really fun
2000. is it like a bmw z3
yeah yeah yeah yeah but not as cool like
the s2000 like a two-seater
yeah i put it on i put it i
i put it on offer up to sell like in the
two hours i put it up i got like 50
messages yeah it's like a collector's
now
oh it's a collector's i don't know i was
trying to show the feed on it and [ __ ]
it's yeah yeah in the in the in the
japanese card
community not like a classic car but
like yeah